Привет. Привет.
Привет.
Нормально? Нормально.
У тебя как?
Да.
Подихонечку.
Подихонечку, подихонечку.
Так и живем.
Так.
Вверх?
У тебя есть странички?
Слева? Слева есть?
Это не здесь,
это слева
тебе нужно проскролить
вверх.
Нет, нет,
не эта страничка.
А, на другой вообще?
Нет, у тебя есть слева
поле, белый,
белый цвет.
Да, да, да.
Вот проскролить вверх нужно.
Куда еще выше?
Ты сейчас на пейдж-эйт.
Тебе нужно вверх
проскролить на нью,
на первую страничку.
Да, вот здесь.
Вот эти все штучки,
которые я спрашивал,
подстраиваешь их?
Да.
Сколько у вас будет девелов,
значит, да?
Чтобы тебе
троек отдавать пушно на ходе, да?
Вот это на английском?
Ты понимаешь английский или нет?
Ну, понимаю, да.
А, да? Отлично.
Тогда я могу не переводить.
Да, потом
переведем.
Цену надо будет здесь убирать,
я так думаю.
Цены не должны это быть.
Потому что эту цену сами они делают
каждый партнер, да?
Если надо с ними общаться,
то нужно фиксировать.
А если это онлайн заказ?
Онлайн мы должны будем перекидывать
от Н-сайт МАКС или куда-то на мобегу,
на этот сайт.
Там уже цена будет.
Если онлайн зарегистрироваться,
зарегистрироваться нашего партнера.
А, окей.
Если онлайн тоже перекидывать,
не здесь?
Только онлайн, да.
Онлайн перекидывает.
А куда он должен перекидывать здесь?
Нет, я думала просто, что онлайн
будет на этом веб-сайте.
Если мы будем онлайн делать
B2C, то есть эти партнеры,
ну, по крайней мере, эти первые, да,
они будут, наверное,
будут проблемой.
Ну, эти точки.
Ну, там идея такова,
чтобы их трафик, эти точки
перенаправлять, да?
Конечно, клиент может зайти,
найти точку регистрации,
трафик не должен собирать
отчет клиента.
Так мы должны перенаправлять
партнеров на этих расставках.
Пока у нас не везде эти партнеры,
нам придется, чтобы их не терять,
перенаправлять на онлайн-дегистрацию
нашего сервиса, нашего сайта.
Хорошо. А что мы можем
отобразить по информации
здесь?
Ну, вот такое, да.
Тут, по сути, мы только можем
отобразить,
как это работает.
Понятно. Найди партнера там,
рядом, да? Найди точку, да?
Да.
И потом...
Ну, вот это тоже описывает,
если онлайн-вариант,
как процесс происходит.
Да, ну, разница-то
нет. А, нет, как?
Наверное, надо описывать
вариант, который там происходит,
у них, да? То есть, что тебе надо?
Ну, то есть те документы, которые тебе
нужны, ну, они...
Ну, я вообще не совсем
понимаю, как это работает.
Если...
Где я эту информацию могу
посмотреть? Как пошагово оно работает?
Вот-вот можешь просить.
Или...
И в чем разница между онлайн
и...
когда локальный?
Для локального тебе же тоже
обязательно появляться там, да?
Ты можешь прислать им
по почте документы или нет?
Ну, да, теперь не по почте,
а вот через чат, например, да.
Ну, да, такой тоже
можно будет делать. Такой или чат,
или вот сам пришел-то какая-то точка,
она может онлайн коммуницировать.
Теоретически, да.
Но это уже второй этап,
это надо думать. Теоретически,
можно сказать, когда сделает онлайн,
вот этот заказ мы привяжем в какой-то точке
чтобы пошел плей номера в пузе.
Как-то так можно. Вот пошагово
вот здесь надо видеть. Вот, видишь?
У нас на сайте.
Я посмотрю.
Потому что, ну, получается, что они тоже,
в принципе, могут здесь выбрать точку,
но они в той...
смогут все сделать онлайн.
С этим партнером.
Процесс как происходит?
Сейчас еще как-то оффлайн,
то есть это оффлайн онлайн такая штука, да?
Процесс как происходит?
Они сейчас приходят
к этим посредникам,
и у них документы собирают и относят
в этот пункт оформления, да,
в гософормление. Там это длится
3-4, ну, 3-4-5 дней, да?
Онлайн, если не онлайн,
а дигитально называется, да?
То есть это не онлайн, а дигитально.
Дигитально они могут в эту точку прийти
и им сразу за 15 минут сделают
оформление.
Вот это две разницы, да?
То есть они физически приходят
на точку,
и за 15 минут у них все
готово.
Да. В том числе и
номера они могут там...
Да, да, да. Ну, и у этих точек
в основном же номера есть.
И они им номера выдают, и они сразу могут ехать.
Получается.
Онлайн,
теоретически,
ну, вот когда мы будем
вайт-легл платформу делать,
мы будем, например, своим точкам давать сайты, да?
То есть будем сайты делать,
например. И у них тоже будет, как в конце их
МАКС, возможность онлайна
оформиться, да? То есть у человека онлайн
это правильно сделать.
Тут вопрос
в деньгах, да?
В этом плане не определился.
Теоретически, да, мы можем или
дигитально оформить, и мы смотрим,
окей, по койню PLC, да, индекс.
Мы даже можем сказать, окей, вот ты точка,
мы тебе передаправляем этого клиента,
то есть как бы ты занимаешься,
из-за этого мы с тобой деньгами делимся,
например, да?
И как бы этот человек уже
ну, начинает потом
этому клиенту номера выдают, и так далее, и так далее.
Но я не могу, я еще до конца не понимаю,
почему, потому что эти точки, они все по-разному
работают. То есть сейчас в такую субботу происходит,
и кто-то 162, кто-то 120, кто-то 140.
Если мы сейчас прийдем, скажем,
мы будем 99 евро работать, эти точки
мы не соглашаемся на это, понимаешь, да?
То есть в этом
как бы суть
всего этого. Ну и вот получается
юзер вел какой-то
адрес, он нашел
точки возле него.
Да.
И дальше что?
Он выбирает, например, точку,
и куда он попадает?
На нашу страничку или прям?
Ну, это в принципе
может два варианта тоже быть.
Это может быть на страничку в рамках
нашего сайта, да?
То есть у нас будут города,
и вот под каждым городом будут точки,
чтобы мы могли трафик собирать.
Я бы так делал,
потому что цель-то какая?
По сути, просто трафик собрать.
В B2B мы не соберем столько трафика, сколько нам надо, да?
Это будет мало.
Но все-таки мы хотим эту платформу
на B2B перенаправлять, да?
То есть это такая как бы...
То есть у нас фокус в B2B,
но в B2B, если мы будем чисто на B2B
сконцентрироваться, то
то мы трафика много не соберем, да?
И таким образом можно тогда сказать, окей,
хорошо, мы B2B, то есть у нас
только может, ну, B2B клиент
зарегистрироваться, да?
И это или точка регистрации,
или автосалон, что-нибудь такое, да?
И клиент, а конечный клиент, который приходит,
он только может эту точку найти.
И вот вопрос, что дальше делать, да? То есть
надо, наверное, как-то потом будет
эти точки тоже дигитализировать, да?
То есть это, наверное, тоже плюс для них будет,
и они за это, наверное, будут готовы платить.
То есть что клиент находит точку,
и там начинает как бы вбивать
все свои данные, что-нибудь такое, да?
И
получать как бы лид.
Понимаешь, что-нибудь такое.
Ну тогда в нашем варианте вот
клиент, он находит город,
там в городе есть бремен, да?
Четыре точки, например. Он кликает
вот это на бремен,
выбирает, и дальше он видит
страничку, где
есть список вот этих четырех точек.
Ну да, поначалу я просто
бы оставил, как эту точку зовут,
номер,
телефона там,
как у нас, да,
адрес, когда они
открыты, входка точки, такой всякий, да?
То есть маленькие
карточки. Да, маленькие,
для начала, да.
Потом может быть, если мы уже у нас много,
или потом можно быть с этими точками
договорить и договариваться, и цены
отдельно делать, например, да?
Или фиксировать цены, например, да?
Регистрация.
Да.
Я не верю, что мы если цены будем надавать,
то есть, ну, старых-то точно нет,
но мы можем, да? Говорим, окей, вот это будет столько стоить.
Или каждый, если
каждая точка будет свою цену делать, тоже такой момент, да?
Клиент будет ходить, получается,
по разным точкам, он будет видеть
разные цены. Немножко странно, да, будет, наверно.
А что ты имеешь,
будет ходить по разным точкам?
Ну, пойдет время, например, время,
у него какая-то точка выставила цену, там,
99 евро, а в Гамбурге 120, да?
Он скажет, блин, а почему в Гамбурге-то
дороже, чем время, да, такое?
И он тоже, в принципе, может
сделать в Гамбурге?
Теоретически, да.
У нас в Гамбурге все пришлют.
Ну, то есть, по всему Германию можно
продлиться через наш API.
Да?
Поэтому я, наверное,
все-таки бы, как бы, на конечном
клиенте бы не заморачивался, да,
точки зрения его сервиса, а просто
говорил, вот есть точки, хочешь, вот, как бы,
вам там оформят за 15 минут. Они пускай звонят,
а лид получает, сами цену свою делают,
образно. Наш, по сути,
нас фокус, фокусный клиент, все равно это автосалоны,
как бы, да?
Это вообще
самый важный наш клиент будет.
То есть, точки регистрации, как бы, окей,
потом их можно, как партнеров, на месте
поискать, да, и таким образом
страничка будет B2B,
B2B ориентирована, просто будет
трафика много будет через B2C клиента
таких, да?
И плюс, на первом этапе, мы просто
будем, если они хотят онлайн оформиться,
мы просто будем на себя перелинковывать.
На Мобегу
или на B2C, да? Вот наш партнер
Мобега можно вам сразу оформить
везде по Германии, да, например?
То есть, а как это можно происходить?
Они вбивают здесь что-то свой индекс,
finding partner,
выходит и городок, страничка с их
города, да, как бы,
ну, как у нас листы эти вот,
они попадают на эту
страничку и тут просто стоит
сожрение
в вашем, как бы,
в городе или в вашем регионе
не существует еще физической точки,
но вы можете через нашего партнера
прямо онлайн оформить.
Как думаешь?
Да.
Нормально.
Ну, и тут тебе надо
цветовую гамму спросить.
Ну, это оформление такое,
очень кончервативная такая штука, да?
Получается.
Какие цвета лучше
использовать?
А логотип ты ему давала,
нет, да? Переделать?
Логотип не получается
у меня с ним хорошо сделать.
А кто логотипа делает, какой
тренер он?
Да я даже не знаю,
кто хорошо делает.
Часть же Петимов.
Ну, вот тут верх черный,
как думаешь, вот что будет,
если будет белый, ну,
то есть вот
когда логотип встраиваешь
черную оболочку,
оно же не всегда может быть,
то есть логотип может быть
где-то и на белом использоваться.
Ну, с логотипом окей,
надо будет посмотреть.
Но здесь оранжевый
и белый.
Нет, это я понимаю,
я имею в виду, здесь оно в черное
вставлено. Да.
Ну, на сайте окей, но если мы где-то будем,
например, потом
где-то еще,
ну, вот так, да, оно будет на белом смотреться.
Ну, да.
Ну, логотип надо поиграться
по тренировку еще посмотреть.
Я пью тоже минимум, ну, вот, наверное,
без драмки лучше, да, минималистично,
так, и вперед, да.
Ну, это просто
я не меняла просто.
Ну, разберемся с логотипом.
Ну, по цветам надо тебе посмотреть,
я не знаю, как просить его,
с точки зрения психологии, да.
Ну, умение,
то есть,
какое лучше, какие лучше, там, может, цвета
использовать, да.
То есть, это консервативная тема такая
для людей.
Ну, а так, в принципе,
все окей, да, получается,
что мы делаем?
Найди человека,
потом тут описываем,
как это все регистрируется,
вообще надо и факузно, вопрос-ответ,
а самое важное, ответ-вопрос и вер, да.
Что здесь?
Здесь fully online, это, наверное,
мы это убираем, вот эти, наверное,
два сравнения можно делать, да,
то есть, не два-три-четыре часа,
например, тут один-три дня,
тут сразу, вот это все, да.
Ну, у нас же есть онлайн
тоже вариант,
то, возможно,
его нужно отставить.
Все дальше встретим, да?
Ну, да. И просто ссылку, да?
Иди.
Хотя
ссылку не надо делать, да?
Это мы убираем цену?
Да, цену убираем,
это оставляем,
ну, и вот тут можно тоже оставить,
все, что тебе надо, все, что тебе надо,
это вышло, надо поднимать, сейчас же так,
с этими нейронками работает,
самое важное, вверх.
Все, что тебе надо.
Может быть, сюда вот над этим поставить, да?
Над этим...
Сравнение таблица?
Над сравнением.
Окей.
Ну, все, получается, потом у нас
будут странички, да, которые вот эти
сначала возьмем, наверное,
для начала.
Вот такие, да?
Одними потом еще города
будем взять, ну, прежде всего.
Но это будет не странички, а даже будут
карточки
с городами, которые...
Тебе надо город, тебе нужен город.
Да.
Гусбург или что-то, да?
Потом...
Тебе надо...
описание типа такого,
тоже на каждый город.
Как можно...
Тут тоже переденковка должна быть.
И вот текст, который будет
запилен под город.
И там еще будет этот официальный
адрес пунктов регистрации, да?
И так далее.
Их можно даже назвать
Суласуштейн.
Вот так.
По сути...
По сути, это же как бы теперь точки
еще те,
прежде всего.
Раихни его, тоже фантастики.
Да.
Но они жестко заморочились.
В плане?
По СИО.
Вот тебе пункт оформления, да,
точка ДЕ.
Получается, вот вниз, если пройдешь,
вот все эти города, видишь, вон сколько их.
И они для каждого города, вот видишь, делают
ленинг такой.
Чего это работает, что ли?
Ну и вот, например, еще такая
штука есть. Вот видишь, у них здесь
номера,
что-то стоит, что надо,
документы. Да, открытие, вот они
Суласуштейн вывели.
Еще такое.
Это они официальные точки регистрации будут.
Это для трафика.
Вот вам госадреса,
куда вы можете пойти сами, да, всякая
фигня. Туда, образно говоря.
Не надо будет формуляра.
Вот, если это официально,
их можно выводить
для СИО.
И все.
То есть, помимо вот этих
локальных центров
партнеров и официальные,
добавить на страничку.
Но они
официальные, их надо будет строить, получается.
У нас оно вот так вот, примерно здесь, видишь,
закончил город,
и у них здесь охрана информата,
как там все работает. Да.
Как там все работает. Что-то про город
стоит и так далее.
И у нас, ну, вот картинка города там
и так далее, да.
И ты, как бы, у нас будет, получается,
когда он ищет свой индекс, он находит
какой-то город,
и город будет высвечиваться,
только не так подлодливо. То есть,
какая-то базовая информация, но она потом снизу
может быть. Вообще вот они, что они попали в этот
город, и там
уже есть точки, которые это,
наши точки.
Понимаешь, да?
Типа вот так.
То есть у нас такая карточка города,
и в рамках этого города уже есть наши точки.
Ну, как у нас тут, видишь,
примерно 8 минут.
Вот видишь, тут
что-то о времени стоит,
как это все делать.
Просто здесь
мы были бы не в таком виде, как мы,
но тут несколько карточек.
Там не будет так много партеров на точку.
Всегда может один будет,
или два. В большом городе может там пять.
Пиши мне,
он же, как Сайк Петердейк, какой-то хитрый патапиш.
Неужели они не оранжируются?
Очень.
Где вход?
Ага.
Увращение, Алёна, смотри.
Привращать не надо,
видишь, сначала шли слишком хорошо,
потом никуда отправили.
Поэтому я бы ориентировался
чисто по нашему списку.
Пока.
Ага.
Или какую-то карту сделаем,
что-то такое.
По сути, да.
Ага.
Может быть, знаешь,
что их могли замочить, да?
Что они спамят слишком,
спамят, да.
Новости я вижу у них здесь.
Новости у них
я вижу тоже есть.
Да, да.
Они за спами ли, наверное,
у них по-настоящему.
Вот смотри, что случилось.
Видишь, когда был в июне, в июне,
когда дейт вышел, вот я.
Всё, она им пришла.
В общем, поэтому надо делать
как бы не для ICO,
образно говоря, да, уже
как спема,
просто делать реально, да,
то есть в руки есть города,
то есть в этих городах у нас есть логика, да,
то есть у нас какие-то отсюда есть
как мы это назовём,
потому что всё равно, да, то есть это
не номера точно, да, отцулёсал с пункта,
дегитальничать, ну, какое-то название,
какое-то кибер, ты думал, да.
И под ними просто будем, задаёшь,
попадаешь на такую
типа а-ля-та по нашу страничку, да.
Мы смотрели
с тобой на наши.
И всё, и
ну, и здесь
уже просто описываем
место, ну,
только не баннером, а
как-то по-другому
описываем место, и
в рамках этого места какую-то информацию
даем по бревну, есть
какое-то, какое-то
открытие, и так далее,
и так далее, и потом просто
хотя это уже может
не надо писать, значит, надо сразу просто писать, что
вот в этом-в этом регионе вы можете
вот так-вот так у нас оформиться, да.
Ну, контакт уже соберём.
Вот такая же должна быть
переденковка между городами, да.
По сути, будет базовая информация
через вопрос-ответы, как
оформить быструю машину, и где получить номер.
Вот такое всё время.
Ты поняла, что да?
Да.
Сильно выморачиваться должны мы.
Ну и всё потом
получается, и дальше потом идём, да.
А здесь что у тебя?
Вот это синее.
Синее это был
макет
макет-сервис
партнёра
по оформлению.
Но нам он не нужен,
как ты сказал.
Это типа, когда уже
юзер вводит город, потом выбирает
точку в этом городе,
и вот эта страничка точки,
где есть дополнительная информация.
Ну да.
Получается такая страничка
должна быть.
Я не знаю, ты сказала, что нет,
вроде бы.
Или должна быть.
Да, если уже партнёр будет.
Да.
У него такая страничка.
До этого есть ещё одна страничка
для этого города, где он там
как карточка повисит.
И такая тоже нам нужна.
Получается, мы там можем писать,
вот время открытия его,
когда он открыт.
Да, тоже сервисы разные.
Там же не только регистрация,
а и другие.
Да, да, да, видос лапель,
вот такое всё можно указать.
Даже и такое можно оставить.
Ну хорошо.
Трэйминатюляция этого фига,
это где ты взяла?
Сделала.
Да, и тут можно указать,
окей, если дигитально сразу,
если мы отнесём, что-то сделаем,
там будет столько-то дней длится.
Ну да, то есть только цены
надо будет убрать, потому что непонятно,
если что надо.
Да, вот эта страничка
по сути уже партнёра.
Просто до этого ещё одна страничка
города будет.
Сначала идёт город,
адрес,
а потом уже где-то там,
в этом городе.
Партнёр будет.
А здесь ещё сверху?
А это как?
Не смотри на это.
Я хотела структуру странички просто продумать
для партнёра,
что нам нужно
на этой страничке, чтобы было.
Всё, и дальше потом идёт,
ну тут надо переименовать,
у нас спать надо.
Ну и тут у нас
для B2B будет
станем нашим локальным партнёром.
Дальше,
если ты хочешь,
white-label-платформу.
Там у нас и автосалоны,
и автосалоны,
и фурпарк,
у всех, у кого есть какие-то машины.
И тут ещё, знаешь,
как бы
стать нашим партнёром,
тут будут разные сервисы.
Понимаешь, да?
То есть,
с точки зрения фурпарка,
нашим партнёром, у них будет своя
немножко программка от нас,
да, то есть собираем система,
потому что у них процессы немножко другие,
как они работают, да?
А если это будет автосалон, у них будут уже другие, например, да?
Да.
То есть, автосалон просто делает оформление,
и автосалоном мы можем ещё
спросить клоуд, мы там вообще можем, как раз можем
подумать, что ещё им включить, да?
То есть, автосалоном можно там
что угодно делать, то есть, у них может там и быть там
какие-то, понимаешь, там, ну,
какие-то инструменты,
с которыми мы с клиентами
работаем, чтобы они свой сайт
могли делать, да?
То есть, какие-то дигитальные штуки в автосалон,
ты спроси клоуда, например,
да? Он скажет, что им надо.
То есть, точно им сайты все нужны,
потому что их нихрена нет у них, да?
Вот эта и тема вся, да? То есть, им можно
агентов строивать, кастома, то есть
кастома-супорт с клиентами, и так далее, да?
Которые у нас так будет свой,
мы им просто не...
Мульти-ченнел, вот эта коммуникация
через сайт, да, с разными клиентами,
ну, такие, короче, какой-то функционал в рамках
и бизнеса уже, да, будет?
Или как думаешь?
Да, странички будут
отличаться, контент,
их контент.
Да, ну, то есть, смотрел
автосалон, базово идет
оформление, и вокруг просто
надо подумать, что они еще могут
делать автосалон, да? То есть, я точно не могу
еще, то есть, понятно дело, они еще
какие-то товары у нас могут покупать,
но у них еще какая-то подводка,
подпором будет ученый такой, где они могут
свой сайт сделать, там,
email в общем,
подумать.
Или мы сначала может не перегружать, наверное, да?
Может, сконцентрируется, может,
на оформлении, наверное, да?
Ну, для начала
сперва одной сделаем,
потом...
Или, например, сделать, окей,
сконцентрируемся на оформлении, и вокруг оформления
просто оно удобное, да, там, должно быть,
сканирую свои документы, быстро
оформляю, и там, да, вот это все.
Такой чей-нибудь из Уликса можно
вставить пока.
И все, и потом тут вайбер, платформ
вайпей был, да, просто.
Угу. Но мне, кстати,
нравится вот этот оранжевый
цвет, мне кажется, что
ну,
он
подойдет.
Вот здесь, где ты видишь
такие карточки оранжевые, то здесь
будут фотки.
Угу.
Мы их поменяем.
Хорошо.
Тогда можно вот эти две вещи
проработать сейчас, да?
Но они у меня есть, кстати.
Я уже драфты сделала
вот тех двух стран.
Да, получается, здесь просто надо сейчас страничку сделать города, да?
Как и внутреннюю,
то есть и
рисовать, когда есть партер,
и отрисовать страничку города, когда
нет партера, и мы перенковываем, да,
на нас самих.
Ну и еще отдельная страничка, где будут
все города.
Да.
Угу.
Окей.
А на Бомбеге вы уже зафига, чем
уже вот эта полностью
дигитальная штука будет, да?
Угу.
И там мы уже все устроим, и оформление,
и номера, ну как-то тогда получше будет,
даже какая-то диджит, и под Бомбегу прорабатывает
даже дизайн.
Там сразу цена будет, да, и все такое.
Окей, хорошо, блин.
Да, давай,
пока. Все, спасибо.